Film Courage: How did you spend your first
few years as an actor and then how do you
spend them now?
Choice Skinner, Actor, Director and Acting
Teacher: Good question.
My first few years as an actor was hard work.
It was some…you know I told my actors the
story about eating eggs, water and donuts
but making sure I had money for my acting
class.
I didn’t even have a car, but I would take
the bus to get there.
I didn’t know how I would get home but God
blessed me with someone who would give me
a ride.
It was all about just being the best that
I could possibly be.
I wanted to be in the ranks of the leading
men of my caliber: Denzel, Wesley Snipes,
Cuba Gooding.
Those were the scenes I worked on and I knew
who I was as an actor and I worked towards
playing those authoritative roles.
I didn’t have a problem playing thugs or
you know, gangbangers.
I loved those characters.
Those are the guys I grew up with so I understand
it.
But I’ve never been jaded in the sense of
like not having the opportunity to play certain
roles.
Listen, in my beginning as being an actor
I worked on as many roles as I possibly could.
If the roles didn’t exist, I wrote them
and I would bring them into class.
And so for me it was just being the best that
I could possibly be to understand the process
of acting and to be great at it and to be
a joy to be around because I understood that’s
how people continue to work with you.
Where I am at now (as an actor), I really
don’t care for the auditioning process.
I don’t care for it.
I do it.
My manager is always on me about it, so I
do it.
I go in.
One of the things that made me not care for
it is knowing the politics behind it because
I’m a producer and a director now.
I know what I didn’t know back then when
I was just acting and that is sometimes even
if you’re auditioning for a role, you’re
already not going to get it because they may
be on the phone talking to the person that
they just offered the role to.
So that’s kind of tough.
Where I’m at now, I create my own content.
I direct.
I write and I have people who call me up and
put me in projects because they remember me
as an actor and they remember my work.
So it can be a little funny sometimes for
me because it’s like listen do I really
want to waste the time and audition for something
that I may not get or do I just continue to
do the process because that’s what that
is, auditioning is part of the acting process.
Yeah, I don’t know?
Where I’m at now, I just love having something
that I write or someone write for me say “Hey
let’s come do this!”
It’s easier.
There’s no pressures, no stress about it
and I enjoy that a little bit more than yeah…I’ve
never been a competitive person.
Even in the marital arts, fighting in tournaments
wasn’t for me.
So with acting I don’t look at it as competition,
I look at it like they say as love.
There can’t be competition in love.
If the role is right for me, give it to me.
I’ll show up for you and I’ll do a great
job.
Film Courage: Do you think that audition grind
is what sends a lot people home or somewhere
else?
Choice Skinner: Somewhat.
I think what sends people home mostly is lack
of money.
People get into the entertainment industry
thinking that they’re going to make a lot
of money and I always tell actors if you got
into the entertainment industry to make money,
you can do anything else.
I mean you can do other types of movies and
make a lot of money.
Acting…it’s a love/hate relationship for
some people because they may have gotten out
of college or they left a corporate job or
they left pharmaceuticals…I knew an actor
who was a rocket scientist but he wasn’t
happy unless he was doing acting.
And they get into the acting world and they
want to make a lot of money and two, three
years go by, four years, maybe five and they’re
not making any money and they’re working
a dead-end job and they start to battle with
that.
And so typically I think typically that’s
usually what sends people home.
The auditioning process has a different experience.
When you hear these stories of like Angelina
Jolie or Mark Ruffalo, they say he went out
fifty times until he got his first role I
believe that everybody’s resilience is a
different level.
I didn’t have to go out fifty times.
I think I went out three times and I booked
my first audition.
I was that type of actor but I could see how
the rejection…because like I said everybody’s
looking for love and even if you were going
out for somebody that you like or you’re
attracted to to and you get that rejection,
there’s a thing you go through.
There’s a catharsis, there’s a hurtful
period you go through.
And I think if you’re going for auditions
and you may be right for them and you are
being told “No, no, no…”
You start to question yourself “Is this
right for me?
Is this really what I should be doing?”
Listen, if we’re all climbing up a mountain,
we don’t know what is at the top of the
mountain until we get there.
The climb is just part of the journey.
Auditions are just part of the journey.
And I do believe that there’s a point where
actors need to know if they are auditioning
actors or not.
Which basically means this, if you go in and
you cannot defeat the nervousness, maybe auditioning
is not for you.
Unless it helps you to book the audition.
Maybe being nervous books that audition?
Maybe you go in, you feel like you did a horrible
and then you get the callback and you book
it?
Like “I was horrible?”
That happens.
But I do believe that there’s a sense that
actors need to know if they are auditioning
actors.
Is this auditioning process for you and if
it isn’t what adjustment are you willing
to make in order to be great at it?
So that way you are not missing out on opportunities
or you’re not wasting your time.